yo yay
happy holidays merry christmas kwanzaa
and hanukkah
cheers what are you drinking i know it's
a little late it's i'm a day late here
but
uh well you go first what is that i got
a makers manhattan
classic i like it and that's
that's uh whiskey vermouth
cherry uh-huh what am i missing
threw some bitters in there bitters i
like and i got the big cube i also i
love the maraschino cherry man you can't
you're not you're having a good time
when there's a cherry involved you can
call me a [ __ ] all you want but
it's a good time ingredient it's a good
time i mean it's the cherry on top
literally you got it like a chocolate
sundae or
anything that the cherry coke you name
it cherry helps
cherry papa cherry that must have been
like when it came on the
puppy when cherry coke came on the scene
that must have been just
hysteria that must have been like the
beatles of drinks
because yeah coke is already like a game
changer right
right when you had the first coke i mean
because cocaine
sure but i mean it's america's drink
it's it's huge
yeah dude i love them manhattan is like
a winter drink to me it's like
it just puts me in a good place yeah i'm
having a lot of manhattans
it's like a holiday drink too because
you're like it's a it's it's bourbon but
it's kind of got that sweetness
i love it it's perfect because it's
subtle but it still has a great flavor
it's it's a perfect man's drink you know
you're still having a cocktail but it's
not some frilly [ __ ] with a
umbrella in it you know exactly you know
what it's like i feel like everyone went
old-fashioned because of mad men
everyone's like
john draper drinks an old-fashioned like
first off don draper will drink [ __ ]
anything
all right he's a man he'll drink he'll
drink a martini
if it's a lunch meeting he'll do a
bloody mary he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
drinks old fashions but
i don't like the straw i like the sweet
vermouth i don't like the straight sugar
i like to lie to myself how much sugar
i'm having
yes good point good point also birth
place
of you which is kind of fun it is fun
like
i got the hurricane which is the
shittiest drink of all time
and it's a tragedy it's like a it's a
what do you call it like a natural
disaster
it ruined my city and that's our drink
and we have a sazerac but that's
that's tastes like dog [ __ ] you wouldn't
drink these as often if they were caught
in 9 11. that would be
yeah there it is there it is hand
grenade you got hand grenades also which
are [ __ ] disgusting
yeah it's a sugary tourist hogwash
yeah you know so all right well what the
hell is shirley temple by the way we
were talking we're talking coke we're
talking cherry
what is shirley temple it's uh it's
sprite
it's uh i think grenadine
okay okay it's weird it's kind of like a
kid's first taste
of like it's like a gateway to cocktails
yes exactly it's like sprite isn't
enough he was like i need i need an
extra kick and you're like all right
yeah and then you put the cherry on it
that's like the dressing
you're right it's a cocktail starter
yeah
it really yeah what do you got i'm going
all i'm gonna make it in front of you
this is a special
special edition so first off shout out
to the mom
for uh what do you call that that was my
gift was the ice cube maker
the round god what a cool mom oh my god
dude that looks great
all right then i'm joining you oh i'm
doing yeah maker's mark i
got to shout out trey wingo my man who
sent it to me send me the bottle
great guy all right wingo look out for
his new podcast that just came out
i'm gonna do a little little two fingers
there much like aziz
and then in the mouth and then we're
going
this is where it gets real sad
oh no it's not sad at all i love it i
love the festive vibe
you're bringing here man one of my
favorite drinks i
i always say uh eggnog is like mariah
carey i'm a fan but
after christmas is over i don't need it
for a year
there we go
oh [ __ ] i should have joined you oh that
looks delicious
it up with a big pig you can do rum too
right or is it oh yeah
okay you can do a rum but come on we're
here yeah what are we pirates yeah yeah
rum is exactly
rum is a bit much right yeah yeah
uh rum it's not as good and it's it's
the weaker
it's not a drinker's choice i think a
real drinker likes a little bourbon
well the well the bourbon cuts the
sweetness of the eggnog a little bit i
like that
oh that's good oh i might have to go
ahead and get some after this that looks
good man
i mean if you need so i can shoot some
over i had a gallon over the christmas
holiday and now i got this i just got
this for the show and it's
it's too much i wonder if they're doing
like i bet they're doing like oat milk
eggnog now i bet they're doing i bet
like they have a healthy
no doubt about a soy uh silk eggnog
what the hell's a nog by the way i don't
know
it sounds dirty a nog nog
i got knocked in the alley
what uh what do you have like a holiday
movie of choice are there any ones you
watch every year or do you mix it up or
what do you do
well i mean this is a one this is a
wonderful life it's a wonderful life
it's always a classic
it's it's so heavy though it's so long
black and white
uh you never saw what i know
it was like never on the list as a kid i
know it's a classic i know i should have
seen it
i mean it's worth it just to sit down
and watch it because it's two hours and
15 minutes but it's heavy like it covers
yeah philosophical thoughts and you know
growing up and life and all that [ __ ] so
it's worth it
yeah but it's it's i mean i've seen it
600 times
i know liszt has always seen it in uh
every time
in the movie theater every december and
i'm just like every year
a a yearly trip to the movie theater
feels like a lot but i get it it's like
a comfort in the
right but yeah i don't i don't know i
don't really have one
uh you know love actually is a classic
it's a
christmas uh then they give them there's
a die hard debate which
is so silly no guy has ever been like
let's watch love actually
i'll tell it it holds up if you got a
romantic bone in you it's
it's something i do and i don't like it
i you know what's interesting i
i saw a girl once and she was like
she we watched played against sam the
woody allen movie and she was like this
is awful
and then she i was like all right you
put on a movie and she made me watch
love actually and i was like oh you
hated played against sam
so i was like immediately like [ __ ] this
movie uh
that movie's got one of my a few of my
favorite lines in it
uh played against sam well his wife is
divorcing him
and she goes you're just not as romantic
as you when we first met and he goes
you want me to keep up the same level of
charm as i did during courtship you want
me to have a heart attack
no wow that's great great line
that says so much that's like half my
act right there so
and then he has another line where he's
trying to pick up a woman in a museum
and she's just the most nihilistic dark
woman ever and he's so turned on by her
and
he says what does this painting mean to
you and she goes that everything is
filled with
nothingness and life is bleak and and
terrible and
every moment we're suffering and he goes
what are you doing saturday night and
she goes
committing suicide and he goes what are
you doing friday night
that's great classic jokes in that movie
it's a great movie
man i love that that i love when a joke
is so good that's a 54 year old joke or
whatever and it still kills
so good so good love actually maybe i'll
give it a shot i
i came in so i like bad santa a lot
that's i was going to say bad say love
actually is fine but if we're talking
comedy
i think christmas vacation is the number
one of all time
oh yeah i haven't seen that one forever
but yeah as a kid i definitely i loved
randy quaid
oh dude so good the uncle with the
toupee the squirrel
elaine is in it from seinfeld i mean
it's a joke a minute and they
sentimental moments but they all end
with a punch they don't leave any scene
too sappy
yeah i like bad santa cause it goes
right to the verge of
not at all redeemable and then somehow
it's redeemable it's like
it's just kind of perfect i heard that
larry david and jack nicholson were up
for that part too and i think they both
turned it down
i think billy bob now i mean larry david
would be able to smarmy
billy bob has that sadness to him he's
got that he looks
decrepit and creepy and and down and out
yeah
he kind of he makes it more dramatic
larry david it would have been
it would have been hilarious but it
would have been like it i don't know if
it would have had the same dramatic
weight
yes yes he'd be more tongue-in-cheek and
then nicholson is is too much where
you're like all right buddy
you're you actually i think you're gonna
[ __ ] this kid and kill it and bury it
you know that fat kid i don't know what
he's doing now oh he's all he's just
perfect though
he's so so good in it man child actors
man
they that is the worst fate of any human
being
i i mean like he said he don't know that
he could be very happy
well i i'm just he wasn't huge like i'm
talking like ricky schroeder and the kid
from webster
like you know those kids in africa with
the machine guns when they're like
seven those kids turn out better than
child actor every one of them's tapped
they're all wrecked
they look like corey hamner like you
poor bastard yeah
yeah yeah exactly he got out easy he
died feldman
feldman's a mess
all of them are ruined it's a tough gig
man yeah you it's tough because like
you think like you know guys who peak
young
who are like star football players at
their high school that
that's got nothing on being a star
a movie star as a child occasionally you
see one like i think chunk from the
goonies is an entertainment lawyer and
you're like oh
all right you lucked out there that's
because you're kind of in that world but
you're like yes
and you're still respected and making
money you see jewish guy
jewish the family kept him in line i'm
sure of it he became a lawyer still he
stayed in show business but like mccully
culkin's weird now
uh what's up what's that guy's name
macaulay culkin was too big though
that's like
like can you can you imagine the [ __ ]
that kid's seen i mean
he defended michael jackson but he must
know something
that's like oh yeah that's like being on
epstein's jet and not seeing anything
like for sure but you're like this is
something's off
right right yeah yeah he he looks
different like his face is twisted
that's the face of i'm holding in a
pedophile secret
for decades what about michael j fox he
was a child actor he got off easy but
he's still he's he's literally trembling
from it
[ __ ] he was the best dude i loved mike
fox
so spin city so [ __ ] underrated such
great
great charlie sheen that's like the rare
show where someone comes in and does a
great
i thought charlie sheen is hilarious on
that show oh i stopped watching after
michael j he's great charlie sheen is
kind of like
i think he gets no love as a comic actor
but he plays it so
straight like yes he's like a totally
dry
straight man i i know like it's not
popular to say but i think he's like
you know what i love charlie sheen they
do but they also like
i think like purists like comedy people
are like [ __ ] that guy he's
you know what i mean oh no i think he's
great i mean i love him and ferris
bueller had like a seven minute park
and he stole the whole movie that thing
was incredible yeah you're right
hot shots he's so hot shots oh man
one of the great spoofs that no one
brings up i know he's one of the highest
paid
tv actors ever i know i know like
obviously the consensus
in the world is that people like him but
i'm not saying like
i think like comedy people are like oh
that should have been that should have
been like a comic actor but like no that
guy
he's so dry and straight that's that you
need a guy like that that's like the
leslie nielsen thing
right and like like leslie nielsen i
think he studied under like lawrence
olivier or some [ __ ] like
he's like he was like trying to be
anthony hopkins and then he like got a
police squad and they're like this is
[ __ ] good there's a little
youtube has such amazing videos as a
documentary on leslie nielsen
and his you're right his early stuff he
was just trying to be shakespeare
and played straight he got some uh
spaceship movie that went nowhere and he
was like the captain
and nobody saw it but he just you know
tinkered along for
decades and then he got this and he was
like ah [ __ ] it i'll take it what else
am i doing and he killed it
right driven naked gun is like
it's just par if you watch like police
squad you're like these one-liners are
just [ __ ]
gold oh like like a [ __ ] at a urinal
i'm gonna have to be on my toes
and there's a million of them that one
oh dude yeah he and dude i mean o.j
simpson it's like so much so
you you relive you're like holy [ __ ]
what a different time oj
was a great comedic supporting actor in
this [ __ ]
i know i know unreal man that movie was
good
yeah joelis always brings up the scene
where there's like three riff-raffs
like at the baseball game and they're in
the queen's box and they go what the
hell get out of here and like
oh sorry they're just like three guys
sitting in the queen sections with their
feet up smoking
so [ __ ] good dude oh it's so good
that's like how about just
all the dancing with the st right
[ __ ] gold oh so funny i was actually
just listening to uh
there's this podcast now speaking of i
listened to some of the
malcolm gladwell on your recommendation
loved it i listened to the one on uh
howard hughes and the guy who wrote the
uh
fake autobio or the fake biography on
howard hughes
ah and he got busted i had no idea this
story existed but it's
completely insane like wait wait wait
wait somebody wrote a fake barbie as a
book and sold it and it didn't
sold it no it didn't it never got
released because howard hughes was a
recluse
i he was a rec loose late in life and
this guy just
gambled he's like look i'm going to
write all these fake flattering stories
like that he like he wrote this chapter
that he told him like it was a fake
interview he and his buddy just went to
like
i don't know where they went they went
somewhere on vacation like the bahamas
or something not that yeah or something
like that
and they would just get [ __ ] wasted
and sit in a hotel room and like fake
the interviews one night one would be
too drunk so he's like i'll be howard
hughes tonight
and he they were just wow tell these
stories he's like ah and then i hung out
with hemingway and hemingway was like
hughesy you're the man
you know so they're just making up these
stories and howard hughes is a recluse
so they're like
banking on the fact that he won't come
out of hiding and they can get away with
this
and and he's described him on all these
shows
he's just like he's like yeah i met him
and and he's so such a good liar that he
they were like uh so
what's howard hughes like is he what
does he look like because there were
stories of his fingernails he never cut
his fingernails right
here had long hair and he said he's uh
he's an older man but with the dignity
of a man who is very good looking like
he just knew how to answer everything
wow that's a real like uh what do you
call it
what's the word for liar uh
when they lie a lot pathological yeah
yeah that's impressive that he went that
deep with it
oh they went so deep and some of the
stories i mean i i was
blown away it was the first one i
listened to and i couldn't believe it so
so fascinating that someone could get
this far with it
i haven't heard this one yet i gotta
listen to that it's one of the more
recent ones
okay i loved it but you made me think
about there's another podcast
i've been listening to podcasts i have a
different recommendation but i was
listening
there's this referee i'm sure you heard
about this guy in the nba
it's called whistleblower tim donahue
was this referee who was like all right
so he would the
nba fans hate this guy because like he
fixed games
in the early 2000s and uh
you know he's a scumbag he would just
fix games like but they lie you're like
you could fix games
you could manipulate games that's the
difference right like you manipulate
them those are calls
you're like well i probably should have
made this call but i could have not but
i can
i can coach i can ref a game where i
like slightly manipulate a game
but i'm not really fixing it and this is
kind of like there's nothing
questionable here because nba is the
only game really i guess football you
could argue too
uh but the ref the ref is the biggest
role in basketball because
because you can call fouls i mean right
you can challenge in the nfl you can't
you can challenge now in the nba but
this was before you could challenge
you know so and even then it's like not
as big a part of the nba as it is
the nfl so this guy so the mob was
involved with this [ __ ] right
there's people it's crazy the story is
crazy i
and i'll give this to the podcast out of
the gate michael imperioli starts doing
voice over and i'm like
all right i'm the target demo for this
like sopranos sopranos and basketball
it's great but uh yeah dude it's
completely insane
wow i mean you always wondered like you
know you always hear
players say that they all riled up
they're like he's he's uh he's biased
he's all for the other team or whatever
it is and it's true i mean
it was true and also i mean there's a
famous game
uh it was the kings versus the lakers
and it was the
the kings like swear they should have
won this game and the lakers got like 40
free throws
so they just called everything a foul
and i don't think he was i don't think
he was referring that game i can't
remember now i listened to it a couple
weeks ago but
it was either him or some other guy that
also had a question there's like you go
through it and there's like
they said there's one by the way they
said there's one ref in the nba who
doesn't cheat on their wife it made me
think of the sopranos would they like
i'll make fun of
they'll make fun of baccala because he
didn't [ __ ] around right
but it's like hilarious can you imagine
listening to that and you're like one of
the wives of an nba player and you're
like well it's not my husband
he's right right it's kind of a genius
thing is you give that one
out you know everybody's like oh it's me
it's me it must be me i'm good
completely crazy and uh yeah i mean
all these guys were kind of most at
least most
most of them were on the take and that
was tim donahue's whole thing was like
i'm not the only one but he's taken all
the heat i mean he's out of the game you
know
he's long i mean obviously he's out is
that jail time you think because i mean
that is like
i think he did some time and i listen it
was a few weeks ago i think he did some
time in jail yeah
wow that's why the mob involved is so
[ __ ] wild it's so old school any
sports betting
you gotta you gotta imagine the mob's
got some stake in that [ __ ] because the
house always wins right so
yeah damn george carl always had he
always ended a lot of bits with like
and then we'll get the mob to bet on it
that was like a big
big punch line at his you know he'd be
like here's what we'll do
we'll electrocute their sack and then
see who dies first we'll get the mob in
on it you know then the heads will roll
the little
holes and you bet on who's you know all
that [ __ ] and uh
i was just listening to some george
today and he had a mob bit like that it
was so funny
that's [ __ ] i tell you something a bit
about how we the mob should do the news
because they already know what's gonna
happen
like a bunch of people were found dead
tomorrow
if any that would kill and then you go
the winning lottery numbers are and that
was like an applause
break that was like a clean a tell that
was like a late night joke
that's beautiful i mean i tell was he
was pretty clean back in the day i think
she kind of had to be a little bit
and he's got a montreal set it's he's
got hair
this it's got to be late 90s or mid 90s
and he's
killing and that joke is in there and
it's such brilliant stuff because
i mean he's brilliant now but it's it's
a lot of this a lot of that a lot of
like
vibrator butt plug or whatever which is
all great [ __ ] this [ __ ] that but
he had to be clean and it's still
brilliant and still
a telly it's so interesting yeah because
like you're right you had to be kind of
cleaner back i remember like mackie and
i
joe mackey and i took this class at the
comic strip when we started
and this guy d.f sweedler who taught the
class was he's a great guy and he would
just always tell me he'd be like
you got to write clean before he can
write dirty and i was like man what
great advice because
great he's right i mean he's like he
said cause he said to me he used to tell
him guys like that as an example he's
like your favorite dirty comics
can write clean exactly i thought that's
such a great that's such a great note
it's a great note also it's a it's real
comedy
i mean i hate to say that dirty is
obviously real comedy but
if you can write a clean joke that's
like okay you've written a joke because
a dirty punch line will get a laugh
usually so if you can write a clean
punch line then you're like all right
you really wrote a real joke
for sure you didn't just you know say
butt [ __ ] at the end or whatever which
that was funny obviously we all have
jokes where we're like man that hit 10
times harder because we said
[ __ ] or [ __ ] and then you're like how
strong is that joke
of course i used to have a [ __ ]
whatever and i said freaking
on tv and i remember i showed up and all
my a bunch of comments like hey what's
up
nice freaking day and i was like all
right did it not hit as hard
yeah it didn't hit us hard but it was so
it really stood out
that freaking because i never say
freaking ah i'm like i'm always kind of
like
if the joke's good it it works either
way but sometimes that sometimes you
need to [ __ ]
i mean i'm not like super judgmental
about that i think sometimes i need to
[ __ ]
i agree well if you if you save them you
know like some people just [ __ ] every
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
but if you save them they can be
utilized
perfectly like uh you had a bit
oh [ __ ] it was in your comedy central
hour
where you said [ __ ] was the punch line
like what the [ __ ]
and it kills now i can't think of it no
damn i don't know but it was the only
[ __ ] in there so that's why where it's
cosby how's that yeah you earn it first
you earn it
cosby's got that bit where he goes uh
yeah
what if he's an [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
cocaine intensifies your personality
he goes yeah oh yeah what if you're an
[ __ ] yeah yeah cocaine yeah exactly
and uh it's just like the it's like a
four minute it feels like a four minute
applause
like they're going nuts because he never
uses them that was a long joke to reveal
the punchline that cosby is a coke head
that would happen yeah he likes drugs
yeah it's so funny that cosby's like the
one who's like self-righteous and like
you know the one they pull you i mean
that's hilarious that hannibal
just destroyed bill cosby i know and it
also proves like a lot of women were
like
nobody believes women nobody listens to
women you're like all right shut up
sister whatever
you know keep cooking and then and then
a man says it it pops i remember mike d
stefano rest in peace mike d who is so
funny uh
i remember i worked the door at broadway
and he went on stage one night and said
something about cosby goes oh yeah you
all [ __ ] like him but uh
you know he's a piece of [ __ ] and he
goes oh yeah and i was like
what i didn't i googled it that night
you know and i remember being like i had
no idea it took a guy
that's how when you're that powerful
that [ __ ] is buried
yes yes lawyers and whatever it whatever
the chunk
from the goonies was burying that [ __ ]
it's true though like it's all very
honorable uh the honorable judge
uh [ __ ] joe pondeliano from goonies
and his mother
and then hey you guys that's how he
walked in
chunk you're a bundle stop calling me
that anyway
yeah yeah it's true
all right fine uh sustained do the
truffle shuffle and maybe
[Laughter]
so um that's interesting yeah he
uh cosby man do you have a do you have a
wreck for this week
well it's a little basic as the kids say
oh it is a little hack but i i don't
know if you've seen it yet
but everybody's talking about it and the
hype is real i know you're gonna say
already
you already know can i guess yeah is it
soul
oh i i cried i had a tear in my eye and
so many layers so many levels
you know brilliant brilliant writing had
a great message
did you see it no no i'm going to see it
i'm going to watch it with salaccus
i mean it is heavy duty like
the fact this is a kids movie is a gift
to children this is like
i mean i'm building it up but this is no
no i've not heard anything
i mean what i love about this is i see
like literally
people on my timeline on social media
who cannot be more different
yes and they're all saying how great it
is so i'm excited to see it
i had the same thing i had a some like
super woke activisty guy
say how great it was i was like oh here
we go and then louis gomez
oh [ __ ] i gotta watch it
[Laughter]
you got you got both louis is a tough
guy so you get the tough guy
badge too yeah because it's it's like a
it's it's a black centric jazz cartoon
so you it almost feels like oh is this
some kind of like
you know uh black blm thing like black
voices
and then you're like no this is a great
movie right so it transcends
oh yeah but i feel like a lot of those
pixar movies kind of transcend
you know yeah they reach kids and adults
they're so well done
pixar is on another level i mean it's so
they're so good and it's hard to get
good movies made now i feel like like
independent
interesting profound thought-provoking
movies
now like pulp fiction i don't know if it
could be made today or my big fat greek
wedding or whatever the [ __ ]
tarantino pitching pulp fixture now he's
in the room so then a guy standing there
he's getting sodomized they're like
please leave our office
yeah yeah but he's black okay wait you
haven't gotten to the scene where a
black guy gets shot in my garage and i
dropped the n-word 14 times
just listen let me finish yeah
but john travolta shoots a guy in the
face but
but yeah but tarantino is a [ __ ]
genius i mean he's a genius meanwhile so
yeah it all works out but yeah but then
again like
with the you need that track record and
even now i heard i heard that tim burton
pitched something everywhere and struck
out he got shut out completely i mean
you know so it doesn't matter your track
record sometimes
no what's the guy uh coppola francis
ford coppola
he pitched something and they're like
we'll buy a movie from you
if it's a mob movie and he was like
jesus christ god it's so [ __ ] and
it's like
i love scorsese i don't need to see
i didn't need the irishman i was more
excited like honestly nowadays
and i'm not look irishman i'm glad i saw
it it was fun
i didn't i'm just saying i didn't need
it imagine i remember showing my
girlfriend the [ __ ]
uh i showed her that first
she had never seen casino or goodfellas
so she's oh jesus
so she's like this is just a way better
version like yeah that's what it is and
then
ten minutes in the casino she's like i'm
good i get it i'm like all right turn it
off
like imagine watch them in that order
it's just [ __ ] weird so
right i want to see different [ __ ] i
love see you see shutter island you're
like well this is different than his
other [ __ ] that's why i kind of like
seeing it you know
right the departed i know it's another
like gangster movie but
it's like a different type of gangster
movie yeah it's irish it's boston
it's police it's not mob but yeah you're
right and it's a different like and even
just having nicholson
instead of de niro yeah all right it's
got a different like i love de niro but
it's like all right at least it's like a
different vibe
true yeah it was alex baldwin matt damon
yeah
yeah
every time baldwin and mark wahlberg
speak in that movie it's like
let's go i mean who are you i'm the guy
who does his job you must be the other
guy
[ __ ] great lines man yeah yeah you
two-faced irish lace
curtain [ __ ] but yeah i like how every
cop in that movie just knows james joyce
i'm like oh you guys just all rejoice
that's all you [ __ ] oh yeah
so good but yeah you showed her the
irishman that's like starting with anal
and then being like look i can eat you
out and she's like no i've already seen
it how about a kiss good i got it
you can't start with that [ __ ] yeah but
yeah
i mean we appreciate i'm with you and
it's uh
yeah no no that's uh it's a tough pitch
now if you're if you haven't
proven it a million and then even if you
have proven it people are like what they
would
they just want what's the guaranteed box
office success but like so many of my
scorsese picks
are not the like i love after hours so
much i love you yes
the king of i mean look how inspired
joker is by king of comedy like you can
retell something without retelling it
exactly that's
that's kind of the point i'm making and
it's almost like feels like they're
making people retell
the exact thing and it's like well
that's just the same thing
we just change is just a [ __ ] little
man i know that's why i hate these
[ __ ] execs these execs drive me crazy
because
obviously they're trying to keep their
jobs they're trying to make money and it
feels like
they're scared there's so much studios
and networks it's all morphing right now
we're in like a transitional period and
they know it and they just want to make
that quick buck and then they lie to you
i mean we've seen it as comedians where
they go oh i love prior i love carl and
you're like
carlin would be struggling right now
he'd have any podcasts he'd have a tick
tock he'd have all this [ __ ] to be it'd
be a nightmare
yeah netflix would be like we have white
comics already george sorry
sorry we know you're really funny but we
have yeah i mean it's hilarious
exactly it's so transparent and the fear
is so
uh is so obvious and i know and then
they then they're such hypocrites
because they act like
oh we need diversity and you're like all
right i'm all for diversity but
i'm looking at the board room and it's
17 white guys and one asian lady like
where's the diversity
exactly you guys get diverse and then
yell at me what the [ __ ]
i know we need diversity it's like all
right white guy named a
white guy named george all right yeah
very diverse
yeah thanks ted i got it now you're
going to get back in your ferrari and go
to your gated community that's all white
and it's like
look i get i'm all for diversity but
like what do you want from here what do
you want from me
i have a hispanic and an asian maid okay
why don't you back off
uh no it's so it's so obvious but uh
yeah i mean
that the problem is they only see the
truth of it is is
they see dollar signs and they and
they're like how can we make money right
now
and then sometimes the [ __ ] you don't
expect is the one that's gonna pop like
i was reading
that jordan peele wrote get out as like
a [ __ ] gas
he's like this makes me laugh i'm gonna
write it he didn't write it thinking he
was gonna sell it
so sometimes you still like i think
maybe that was because it was like
five or six years ago or maybe that's
because like i mean i
think about that like a horror movie
that's racial
like like that's a [ __ ] hard sell i
think oh
for sure yeah definitely but i think the
country was
it wanted it so bad it was that was a
huge hit it's such that's one of the
best movies the last 20 years i think
yeah that was timing too that was all
timing yeah that was perfect
they also changed the ending they
changed the ending because it was gonna
be darker originally and people wanted a
more uplifting ending
and by uplifting i mean his uh white
girlfriend uh stabbed the death in the
street
or whatever where where do you go with
what's the darker one
right the darker one is that as he's
killing her the cops show up and arrest
him
and uh and rael and rel shows up
and in prison and is like what the [ __ ]
happened like so it's
so the darker ending is like everyone
dies and he goes to prison
right which like yeah like i'm glad
that's not the [ __ ] ending i wouldn't
want to re-watch it as much
like you are you are looking forward to
him killing all those [ __ ]
that's a good point yeah that that's
that's a good way to end it because at
least there's some
some relief at the end but you bring up
the the the police and the black and i
i thought i had a good point here people
keep doing like the
santa claus is black and i thought he
can't be black because he would have
been killed by now
i mean a cop he's in a house a cop would
have shot him
it wouldn't work he'd at least be
arrested
did this get met with resistance by
someone
but i'm saying i'm with jordan peele
here this could be a great jordan peel
christmas movie oh yeah black santa
wouldn't work because the
the first house he would get popped
that was that was my big another big
deal another gig that tim allen loses
yeah exactly and he would he'd be late
all right but no
i tweeted this and like all these black
guys like hell yeah that's
too true funny but too true it was a
nice moment but
yeah yeah that's funny that's a good
angle uh
yeah that's there's something there for
sure that there's something about i'll
give you my wreck too as well
oh yeah this guy uh paul never wrote an
amazing book
i want to shout him out on our thing
it's called the knicks
of the 90s it's incredible so good i
wrecked it to
biggest nick fan i know is uh jerry
ferrara yeah oh wow
so i had him send one of him too he
[ __ ] he tweet he was like this is one
of the best things i've ever read too
it's
you can't get bigger praise from knicks
fans than me and him because we're the
most
[ __ ] die hard there's this one story
in it that
dude these 90s knicks were like so
anthony mason was like one of the
enforcers on the team and he would
always say like we're either gonna win
the fight or we're gonna win the game
like we're gonna win one they were so
tough
and pat riley was like our cool ass
coach like slicked hair armani
like decked out well-dressed and uh
he was intense like he was he was like
you better [ __ ] fight you better give
it all and they never won but they were
just the coolest [ __ ]
this close team they went through jordan
you can't jordan's gonna
make it hell so after a game like he was
all about trusting teammates and this
one story i just loved is like
he they got blown out he was so angry
and he's in the locker room
and he takes his head and just in his
nice ass suit just dunks his head under
ice water
in this ice bucket and he won't take it
out and they're like
is he killing himself what the [ __ ] is
he doing finally someone just grabs him
and pulls him out
eyes bulging snot like everywhere and he
goes
that's what the [ __ ] trust is i was
gonna wait till one of you
help me and i was just like holy [ __ ]
whoa how great is that story's like that
so knicks of the 90s it's on amazon it's
it's worth the read if you're
if you love not just basketball but just
great stories it's just
it's it it took me back to being a child
and
loving this team more than anything and
wow where's that
30 for 30. they they have a couple they
did one
reggie miller versus the knicks but it's
[ __ ] it's a bummer because
spike lee is funny as hell on it but
it's like it's a bummer because we just
it ends on the knicks losing so that
bums me out and then uh
michael rappaport directed the got when
the garden was even eaten
uh when the garden was eaten sorry oh
great time
yeah it's uh it's a based on a book by
harvey eriton who's a
new york times writer who's [ __ ]
great so the book is
the book is a little better than the
movie uh but the movie is
it's solid it's just the movie is you
can't
recreate some of the [ __ ] that's in the
book it's like so right i mean having a
mixed race team in the 60s 70s in new
york is [ __ ] symbolic when
they're the most uh you know
chemistry-wise the best team so that's
kind of like
that's kind of heavy so it's hard to
capture that [ __ ]
and uh and also dave the buscher's dad
so you're missing like one of the big
guys but uh anyway that's my wreck i
loved it that's
that's great so wait a minute wait i
mean forgive me here because i'm from
new orleans we have the saints and
they're notoriously bad but then they
won the super bowl and that was an
amazing game
2010 and that was and that was after
katrina so the city exactly
the city rallied behind you know drew
brees and all those cool players you had
i mean that was a cool team man
yeah we needed that and uh but my
question is were the knicks
ever because all i hear about the knicks
is like a punch
line you know yeah i mean i i saw the
clip from the movie soul i saw that
going
on uh they [ __ ] on them but what were
they
good were they bad have they ever been
great what's the word there
they won in 69.70 and they won again at
72-73 and they haven't won since then
those are the two times they won
uh the the play-by-play guy for the
knicks the commentator walt frazier was
on the team
and they won he was the star he was
awesome he's
[ __ ] hilarious he's still the best
but uh yeah yeah i mean it's been a
while the 90s they were very competitive
they always came like very close they
lost in the finals twice so they were
close but
yeah dude my first memory of basketball
was losing to houston and i was just
like
i was like i was like oh clearly we'll
win if we're this close we lost by
one game so and so it was like set me up
like i was spoiled with this team of
characters and cool guys and they just
they never
figured it out so it's brutal but um
yeah
you know it sucks as new york is like
the city you know it's it's
it's the jewel of america whatever
biggest city in the world
new york new york minute never sleeps
and then l.a
kind of sucks they're not they're not
new york let's be honest they got their
moments they got the beach and the uh
sunset boulevard and hollywood but they
win it they win so
it won so many yeah it's tough like
boston has the most but boston won like
a shitload of them in the 50s and 60s so
it feels like la has the most because
they had they like throughout time
they had chamberlain and jerry west i
mean you're not a hoops guy but you know
these names
yeah just from [ __ ] you know who wilt
chamberlain is right he's also the only
guy to drop a hundred in the game
wow well and then between that was magic
johnson and kareem abdul-jabbar so
and then now it's lebron and anthony
davis so like they've never really had a
long stretch
of sucking so right yeah yeah it's tough
i mean
and uh new york is like you every other
block
there's a [ __ ] court like it's such a
i know it's it's in our it's in our dna
here so yeah
it's tough but also like i'm okay with
losing
as long as you lose with character sure
it's just we've been horrible for so
long now but like if you lose
like in the the 90s knicks lose it hurts
but you're like oh at least we're
[ __ ] cool at least i'll like rep this
this team you know yeah but then you got
brooklyn right over the
over the water there and they're doing
great they're gonna be in the finals i
think they're so good
is that weird is that bittersweet it's
heartbreaking
yeah cause you're like you're right here
it's just a different borough but it's
still new york but you're good and we're
not what the [ __ ]
well durant kevin durant and kyrie
irving are two of the best in the league
and they chose the nets over us the
rumor was that they want to come to the
knicks but like
one thing that it's like they just said
the knicks aren't cool that's what
durant said and then
what yeah it hurt man and then also the
knicks make all these dumb mistakes like
our practice facilities in westchester
who the [ __ ] wants to go to westchester
now we're going to jump on the metro
north just exactly well i don't think
they're
i think they got a car service but who
the [ __ ] like you don't want to sit in a
[ __ ] car
that's a half hour i mean more yeah in
traffic i don't you don't want to
so it's like also when you're sore
wouldn't you rather just be in brooklyn
like i don't get why you can't just get
a practice facility
so that that sucks and uh yeah all these
little things we were like yeah i mean i
just
in my heart i can't i can't my brother
and i went to a game once and he was
like i'm gonna be a nets fan a few years
ago and i was like all right and
i can't fight you and then he showed up
in a knicks jersey to the game and i was
like
i [ __ ] knew it he's like yeah i can't
leave so you know all right
you relapsed but but that's the thing
it's like yeah it's not cool but let's
make it [ __ ] cool
uh also i think it is cool but let's
make it cool it's like hey look we went
on youtube to do our specials
that was a that was a loss in our eyes
but now i love youtube now i'm like [ __ ]
it youtube's the spot
yeah this is a fun spot and this is fun
what we're doing right here is fun so
yes i love the the eggnog looks [ __ ]
good man
it's going down too easy i gotta slow
down dude that's the thing these
manhattans i'm gonna have like
five of them because they're so they're
so good that's the thing
i know speaking of which it's gonna be
weird i'm in tampa this weekend and uh
bobby jewell's not gonna be there oh man
my face sold it right
yeah mike can i tell my favorite bobby
jewel story
please please bobby jewell for those
listening who don't know he ran this
club
called side splitters in tampa just
ridiculous guy like
would just [ __ ] on you [ __ ] on you yeah
shows up in like a charlie sheen two and
a half men shirt
but then he's like 58 half in the bag
got a [ __ ] pinky ring a hairpiece
shows up
drunk in a mercedes to pick you up from
the hotel blasting jersey boys and
you're just like i mean this is see this
dude is he's a new york guy but he's
like
all florida now it's like the new york
has left him he's become florida
so uh yeah what's up [ __ ]
that's his greeting here we go you
[ __ ] liberal new york
[ __ ] queer that's what he would call
me and i'd be like hey bobby
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and his big one would
go you get two inches from my face and
go i leave pieces of [ __ ] like you in
the
dirt and i'm like yeah you can out drink
me at 58 that's a bad sign
that's not good yeah you smell like a
strip club
and you look like the owner what is
going on
he looks like hell dude he's so i
remember they put me in the condo one
year
uh and i was i'd been that shitty little
condo so many times you know coming up
featuring there
and and there was like a bigger room and
i walked there and the guy was opening
for me a great guy i end up becoming
buddies with him but he's in the
room and i'm like it's my birthday and
i'm like i'm depressed already
so i like go on morning radio trashing
them to mike kelta who's like the big
radio guy there
yeah and mike is like wait he put you in
a condo not a hotel and i was like yeah
he's a cheap piece of [ __ ] and i start
trashing him
and it's killing on air and i get off i
get off radio and someone goes there's a
phone
call for you and i'm like uh oh and
bobby it's bobby and he goes
well played the hotel awaits he has
someone drive me to a hotel
you see he's a decent human after all he
respected that i went at him on public
like instead like he's like that's how
you do it you trash me publicly
it's like an old school mentality i love
that and i remember he said to me once
he goes you know what he's pissed drunk
he's smoking a cig ready to go you know
what i want to see
you joe list and nick apollo
own a room tearing each other to shreds
he said i said why would i i like both
of them why would we do that he goes
gosh it's like a [ __ ] villain he's
just
wow i love it if he was in a movie you'd
go
you got to tone it down and over the top
you got to bring it
bring it back and dial it too i had dina
hashem
open for me at uh one of the weekends
there and he cooked for us he's like let
me cook you a steak
and i'll cook you a uh like a real
dinner in my place and we get there and
uh
and you know it's me it's bobby it's
dina he's in the car already like tell
me like he had just had like a
girlfriend who for the first time he's
like
we're finally making it work and i'm
like oh that's great and then when he
picks me up in this ride he goes
we broke up and i was like oh my god i'm
so sorry you're okay and he goes
please i was about to leave her in the
dust myself
there's never a vulnerable moment and uh
so then he drives us to the place he's
got he's got the model home
so it's like nothing has changed like
this is the way they show the house he
just kept it that way
so there's no heart to the home it's
just like this is how it would look
if you were showing the the home right
so he's cooking the steaks he's
feeding pouring his wine baked potatoes
great size he's
a good cook wow and then i was like wow
what a lovely and dino is like i can't
believe he's this
kind like i'm yeah so then we're at the
club later that night
you know he she's like i wonder if he'll
show up and i was like oh he'll show up
even the bartender says don't make don't
say his name three times he'll be here
don't worry
he shows up like a [ __ ] sitcom
character he just like he just walks in
and like poses like he's
like he's waiting for applause he's like
right
right and and as he walks in he goes you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i was like what what did i do and he
goes i [ __ ] cooked you
a steak and i was like yeah you invited
me
you would find what you want me to say
and he's like you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
just two inches from my face breathing
that [ __ ]
whiskey all over me yeah one more quick
one
i would so the weekend i'm there with
raul sanchez who's hilarious who's a a
buddy of mine
he's opening he's so funny he's doing
bits about
uh you know being a like doing combat in
iraq i mean he's like a [ __ ]
wow he's like seen [ __ ] he's got ptsd
he's open about it
and he's a mexican guy he's and bobby
keeps calling him indian he's [ __ ]
hammered
and he goes he's hammered he just he's
rigged he goes hey raul
his name's raul by the way hero killer
by the way i forgot him that guy's great
he's a beast yeah
and his [ __ ] is like i've never heard
someone doing like hard punch
military material like that it's [ __ ]
impressive yeah
and bobby goes hey raul he goes hey
rubble
what tribe are you in yeah and raul goes
airborne infantry how about you and
bobby goes
well played
oh man yeah he's a character i mean
one time he pulled up and i had like a
hot set that's a club you can really
kill it i feel
like it's a hot club great club and i
walked out on the bar i was like give me
a tequila whatever and bobby walks in he
goes
hey is it sold out i go ah we were like
a couple tables short he goes
you make me sick got it
went back into his shitty bend with like
a two pit skank and drove off into the
sunset
brutal you make me sick he would do i
remember i was like hey let's do a promo
video for the weekend so i'm
recording him and he goes uh he goes
samurail
best comic in our price range
wow that's pretty great he's pretty
funny that's funny
oh man he would just be wrecked
constantly at the bar and it was like
there was always a moment where he was
kind
and then there was that one drink where
he would just turn and you're like oh
boy it's gonna be a long night now
and then people would be looking at him
across the bar i remember he was acting
like a drunken fool and he's like
pushing 60. so people are laughing to
see an old guy drunk like that
and some guy across the bar it's his bar
is laughing at him and he goes
the [ __ ] you looking at you piece of
[ __ ]
not to mention the more he gets
shit-faced drunk drunk and his wig he's
got a shitty toupee and it's like
it's like over here by you know 11 30
and he's like ah give me another one you
[ __ ] gun
oh man so classic you piece of [ __ ]
it is hilarious that he sells the bar
right before coven hits
like of course he would dodge another
[ __ ] bullet i know i know he's
he's bulletproof that guy but i don't
think he's happy
if it if it helps i mean he was a i
gotta give me the funny dude like he
always
he was oh i mean we are i mean look how
many [ __ ] stories
i mean that was the thing i was telling
dina i was like this is the last
version of this yes you got to enjoy
enjoy this weekend i mean he's just so
inappropriate
and yeah he's like 80s club owner i mean
he's got stories about kinnison and like
jimmy schubert and bill hicks and all
that [ __ ] all those like
ron bennington all those florida guys oh
bennington's a [ __ ]
beast yeah he could go on all day and
yeah i don't know
hope he's doing well i i i you never
know with that guy
yeah there was just so many incidents
where he was just so
[ __ ] inappropriate and uh so damn
funny though
i mean yeah yeah shout out to and bt and
leslie good
good people doing a great job at that
great club
yeah great staff great club that what's
that that bartender was from brooklyn i
forgot his name italian guy
what is it vinnie vinnie yes vinnie was
cool
in new york yeah he's got stories for
days yeah i mean he's a great dude
yeah uh wait [ __ ] did we cover
everything you got a pet peeve
i got a lot of pet peeves right now man
give me a give me a hot one
what's one that's really grown in your
gears oh it's grinding my gears
okay so this is pissing me off i uh
like everything is [ __ ] automated now
everything is bad right now i sound like
a grandpa but like dude
anything that goes wrong they're like oh
we can't do anything like
i'll give an example i went to [ __ ]
best buy the other day so you can you
can
buy [ __ ] online and then do store pick
up right
so like all right yeah i bought then you
go to the store and they're like oh it's
not ready i'm like
not ready it's in the store since i'm
gonna go get it like it's gonna be at
least 15 minutes i'm like
15 minutes like and of course it takes
longer and i'm like
i can find one in the store just yeah i
already paid for it just get so you're
just sitting there like an [ __ ]
so i get i get a new computer because
this shit's crass you know crashing all
the time
and i get home and like you know little
[ __ ] we need like microsoft word we need
obviously you know i got a mac so it's
like
you need to buy it and like so i buy it
and they're like oh yeah it's not
available right now and i'm like it said
instant download and then i'm so you
can't even get people on the phone it's
all
on it's on the uh computer so i'm
talking on the computer and i'm like hey
like what's going on he goes oh yeah
this happens all the time and i go why
that's a bad product it's called instant
download
[ __ ] give me the instant so it's like
i mean best buy is really incredible
we're like
same where they're like all right we
have the best value and i'm like you
have the worst service i've ever [ __ ]
seen in my life like it's incredible
like and i get it it's a pandemic no one
wants to do the [ __ ] everything's a mess
right now
but like that's why i need some
stability in my life it is a pandemic
just make a [ __ ] app download can you
can i just have one thing
i i tried to buy the nba league pass it
just won't work
and they don't have it's like a billion
dollar multi-billion dollar organization
they don't have a [ __ ] customer
service on the phone
so everyone i talk to online is like hey
oh yeah we don't we don't know what's up
and i'm like
so [ __ ] get a phone line yeah exactly
but they don't answer the phone cause
that's another guy they got to pay
it's a nightmare that they've actually
figured out a pretty
genius system where they just have an
automated thing and it just
is so annoying that you go i'm out
[ __ ] i give up yeah but then
now you're going to your credit card
company like hey [ __ ] you i'm not paying
for the like it's all going down to the
credit card company now
right right and then they go well he
already paid and then you got to cancel
it and that's kind of a pain in the ass
so you go ah [ __ ] then they just got
your money
yeah it's all it's all a [ __ ] pain
right now that's my pet peeve it's
it's just generic but like just like
the world is [ __ ] on fire just let
like let's let basic
shopping be decent like we've got the
technology
with and and computers are just taking
human jobs
and guess what they're doing a bad
[ __ ] job let's get a human let's get
a human to do that job
i'm always the guy put zero press zero
because you just want the lady give me
the lady
that's all you want uh it's a nightmare
but i
assume they deal with such lunatics and
idiots that
that they have to do that automated menu
just like weed out those people like oh
you just forgot that you had to plug it
in
all right push three and we'll help you
do that but
but yeah it's still like give me the
[ __ ] operator give me a human
what do you have for a peeve i'm with
you on that i hate the automated i hate
it
i i can i can even do stuff on automated
with the bank and i just go to the bank
i'd rather just not
go to the bank too yeah i'd rather go
the bank
uh mine is uh with my my gal
i don't know if your lady does this but
uh
this hit me the other day in the shower
and i said i gotta tell samsonite this
because it's such a [ __ ]
pain uh the the uh
it's always not good enough like
we were on a trip we went to italy and
we're in the amalfi
coast this is i remember that i couldn't
i couldn't believe you did a vacation
you you're like me where you're [ __ ]
list always says we're married to the
sea
yes exactly c word
and uh it was the amalfi coast where i'm
in a [ __ ] hawaiian shirt i got
flip-flops on
and we got a drink in our hand and we
got sunglasses on we're laying on a
beach chair
on the atlantic or whatever ocean that
is and i got a peyronie in my hand and
she goes
where should we go next what are you
kidding me we're here now you got to
live in the moment you psycho what are
you doing
this is it what do you mean next nick
this is it
you know what it is because women are
planners man i hate to generalize but
they're planners
and and it's like women respect a plan
more than anything it could be the most
generic [ __ ] but if you're just like
hey we're doing chinese food tonight i
got us this is what we're eating
if you want to add anything let me know
but like if you if they if you
show that you put any thought into
anything
yeah sometimes i get upset with that too
and then i realize i have to be like you
don't have to [ __ ]
say hey i'm not married to this but
maybe we go here next
right right right i just you just feel
so unappreciated you're like well what
about this i want you to be blowing me
because of this trip right now look at
this sunset look at these mountains look
at these
you know everything is great how about
we go to a gratitude usa
you've never been yeah
yeah yeah population one give me
something
yeah i'm with you i'm with you yeah that
that's a huge pet peeve and
it turned out great but you're right
about the planning the planning the
planning can get you laid like on a
first date
if you go i got i got us reservations
but first we're gonna get drinks
then i know a great ice cream spot
they're just like ah panty cropper
dildo the whole thing there should be a
tech support
for that uh-huh this complaint it's got
to make it through like three robots
before it [ __ ] gets to me
hey that's a bit write it down but
here's the clinker
here's the thing is uh oh [ __ ] i lost my
train here
damn clinker damn it
oh here's the thing is i i hate planning
yeah i hate i i like you know the guy
who's like we're
at a barbecue and he's like i'll take
the grill i'm like great
you grill i don't want to grill and i
don't want to plant either
well it sounds like you just don't have
to work either like the grilling is work
that is like that's like an elephant
yeah but some guys are obsessed with the
grilling like it's like
all right you're just [ __ ] flipping a
piece of meat let's not act like you're
[ __ ]
you know you're not mario batali here
yeah wolfgang puck over here yeah you're
turning it over at a certain time no i'm
with you but i think the grill guy is
like i don't want to talk to anybody so
i'll do the grill
yes it's also the alpha that's the tony
soprano roll the grill
exactly it's a status thing i guess
cigar and mouth cocktail in hand spatula
the whole thing but i don't want to be
that guy i'd rather hang out
i'd rather hang out too i also think
like i'm with you with the i think
planning
is i'm not a planner i have bad add
i i leave things alive i feel suffocated
by plans same
someone's like someone's like let's hang
out wednesday i'm just like [ __ ] can we
just like i'm
i'm drowning right even if it's
something i want to see i feel drowning
yeah yeah i totally get that i mean
michael palisack has that great joke
he's like i'm really stressed out i have
a six a.m flight in four months
you know it's like it's so true it's so
perfect but i love i love mullany's joke
about uh
when people say he goes i'm really
lonely and his friends go well we should
hang out and he's like that's not what i
meant
relatable social related so relatable so
good he
he's great but yeah it's it's it's so
true that like
i hate planning and women are turned on
by it but i'm like well can i just be
turned on by stuff that you don't want
to do
that that i like oh i'm turned on by uh
you know paying my car payment you know
like oh so you got to do that now
i thought we were going to go back to
anal i'm turned on by anal is that
[ __ ]
hey the truth is we are turned on by
[ __ ] they don't want to do
yeah yeah good point good point
i guess i guess it could be worse the
truth is we're all annoyed that's what
it comes down to
we're annoying in different ways and
that's like that's something we just
have to [ __ ] play ball that's
something we just
say yeah all right let's [ __ ] plan i
mean reservations were made for women
ah good point but here's but don't you
don't you worry about her like i go i'm
too almost i don't say i'm too
considerate but i'm like
worried like okay i'll make a
reservation here but
in my mind i'm like did she even like
greek now what if i make a reservation
and we get to this red she's like i hate
greek i gotta be honest with you i
appreciate the reservation but i hate
this [ __ ] i'm like [ __ ]
i'll tell you this right now i have an
issue with people that write off any
cuisine
i'm [ __ ] i'm in on any cuisine you
take me anywhere
you take me greek chinese thai japanese
italian greek i will find [ __ ] on the
menu i'm i'm
i'm so annoyed with people who write off
an entire genre
i don't care for that either i find it
to be a genre the right word probably
not
cuisine genre type of cuisine
ethnicity i don't know like you're
writing off a whole group of people
right i agree with you but you can't
find something on a greek menu it's
great food
it's great food it's closed-minded is
what it is it's almost bigoted
in a weird way like you're you're being
dumb by not allowing these new flavors
into your face
i also like i want to try new [ __ ] even
if i don't like it and also like i get
i get it there are nights to play the
hits but there are nights to adventure
man like going to adventure have some
[ __ ] have some grilled octopus have
some [ __ ] kebabs man live a little
have some grape leaves some what have
you what do you call it the the fish egg
like kind of spread they have the grease
no it's not caviar it's like that
i forgot the name it's fan someone will
write in the comments i'm sure yeah uh i
mean [ __ ] greek food rules man
i love yeah i love all that stuff i love
trying new food but i have a friend
who's a super picky eater
and he always gets mad at me because i'm
like try this it's so good he's like why
do you care what i'm going through and
i'm like
well if i get a water at the bar you
call me a homo so like what what
what's the difference i'm saying you
might enjoy it as a friend i want you to
enjoy something new but he won't try it
there's nothing wrong with knowing what
you like but
i do get annoyed when people write off
an
entire group of like you can't find any
i get it like oh chinese is a little
heavy i'm like well they have vegetables
you can get a [ __ ] veggie dish with
the sauce in this you know what i mean
like
i i don't want them but if you want that
[ __ ] i understand like all right if
you're a [ __ ]
vegan we won't go to a steakhouse but if
you're a vegan you should be able to
find something
it's tough when people have weird
dietary restrictions and that just makes
your life hell
exactly yeah you picked this this path
down to [ __ ]
shitville why do i have to go down it
like you should adapt to me
yeah i'm with you i i i think uh
you know i don't know people in like the
[ __ ] midwest
do like i don't know vegans in like the
midwest do it
no my brother's a vegan in new orleans
which wow
it can't be easy but you got whole foods
you make it work you make it your new
one was a big city but like
i mean [ __ ] the amount of temptation i
i'd want a gumbo
i'd wanna i know i know but he grew up
with it it's fine i think he gets it but
also he'll make some vegan gumbo and
it'll be interesting and new
and but i think a vegan restaurant in
the midwest is almost like a gay bar in
the 40s
you know like they all go to that one
and
people make fun of it it gets [ __ ]
thrown through the window but like
that's all they want yeah now you're
right i mean
and also i i get it like the health
benefits they're pro athletes who are
vegan they seem to be
all right like look that's tough for me
yeah i can't do it i
i i've been to good vegan restaurants
i'm not like i'm not like opposed to the
idea of it i just
it's just very hard to do it's too hard
it's too it's i can't give up eggs eggs
is
maybe the biggest one for me well here's
where my brother's a [ __ ]
is you know i love the guy but he does a
v he does thanksgiving at his house
which i'm like let's just have it at
mom's house he's like no i want to do it
i want to cook i want to have it but
it's vegan so now thanksgiving's ruined
because he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] what
what does he do does he do does he do
like uh
like a fake turkey or something he he'll
do a turkey
like a half turkey like a big turkey
piece for us
but then the rest is like some kind of
bread
and then who wants who wants vegan
stuffing stuffing is the star of the
show
of course of course it's horrible it
doesn't work
if this is good fellas stuffing is joe
pesci that's that's the [ __ ]
breakout dish i want a little sausage in
that [ __ ]
uh yeah i can i can get down with veggie
sausage i like i like like the beyond
burger veggie sauce
but i like the taste it's not like i'm
doing it for like a [ __ ]
thing yeah you do feel a little better
after you eat it too
you do but it's like hey this is our our
one day to splurge like animals and
give me the gravy i love the gravy i
want to put gravy on everything but
gravy
needs a lot of animal fat and beef stock
or whatever the [ __ ] and it's all it's
all everyone
there's no excuses indefensible looks
like olive oil
completely indefensible and and yeah i
mean he should he should feel terrible
about himself
yes what else do you have any anything
else
you want to do news story uh [ __ ] i had
something hold on hold on
what do you got on the you got any news
yeah there was a story about a girl's uh
a girl scouts rebuking uh boy scouts and
escalating recruitment war
but i wanna do a thing about how like my
angle on this is like how girl scouts
just have a better name
you know what i mean like you think a
girl scouts and you're like oh that
still sounds good to me
whereas boy scouts i just think of
pedophilia girl scouts i think of
cookies boy scouts i think of like
child molestation because there are no
boy scout cookies
you know what i mean yeah good point boy
scout cookies to me
are like uh and maybe there were
or something but like girl scouts are
like here how if boy scout like cause
boy scouts i think like they raise money
for
the camping trips and i wouldn't want to
support that i wouldn't be like all
right so if i buy these samoas
uh an old man will take you to the woods
that's right
that's where it's going right right
that's that's hilarious
that's one thought i had so that was one
headline i saw on another headline i saw
was uh
this might not be anything either but uh
long covet symptoms
might include disgusting smells of fish
that's a new one
that's a [ __ ] horrible time to live
in china uh
like here at the wet market already well
i just think like a doctor's like you
got to go
somewhere that isn't a fish market and
he's like this hospital he's like now
this hospital has a fish market in it
everyone
everywhere in china's got a fish market
right
right that's so true i've been to china
the whole place smells like fish like
literally like the state capital
uh the museums it's all fish that's
where it started
the [ __ ] covert thing yeah no that's
hilarious so that's got to be tough
being china yeah or or chinatown we've
all been there that place smells like
fish on it was there recently what uh
what
what store what's your story by the way
it's chinatown i haven't been there
is it doing okay or does it look weird i
went down there to do a show
uh it was it was fine it was it was
seemed all right i mean [ __ ] you know
it's
it's the same as all new york right it's
like yeah it's
weird uh it was it was a few months ago
so there was
indoor dining i guess that's [ __ ]
shut this [ __ ]
situation man jesus brutal man i i hope
we're at the beginning of the end with
the vaccine
and the whole thing but 2021 maybe i
don't know but
it's i think we're all pretty sick of it
oh yeah
what uh what's your story so fun story a
happy ending
a man was about to commit suicide
speaking of chinatown happy ending
chinatown jake so a man was about to
commit suicide with a gun
in to the temple and his dog knocked the
gun out of his hand
and uh now he's like glad he did it
wow oh my god that's crazy
my joke was thank god he had a dog not a
cat because the cat would have helped
him load it
you know they can't be like hold on oh
that's not enough bullets there
i hate you any other animal goldfish
yeah go ahead
yeah yeah exactly go ahead hope your
head falls in the [ __ ] tank and i'll
eat it
that's something for sure there's a
whole angle you don't go down with cats
or whatever maybe the dog just didn't
want him to die because he wanted to get
keep getting walked or who knows
something that
how about any other any just regular
bits you're working on
oh yeah um so i had a bit about uh
tell me if this is anything it's a
two-parter so i dated this chick from
the bronx once and she was like this
tough
tough puerto rican chick and she uh she
always said she should have been a
female ufc fighter
but she was very vain she was like
obsessed with how she looked and i was
like there's no way you could be a
female ufc fighter
because they put your age and weight on
screen
you know like that to me getting punched
in the face for a woman
is way better than having your age and
those are the two things you're not
supposed to ask a woman
so like like imagine if they did that
for men
they'd be like oh you want to be a
fighter you hell yeah i'm the toughest
guy on the block all right well we got
to put your dick size and bank account
i love that i knew dickside was going to
be one of them but i still love it yeah
it's perfect that's really funny
and then i had this this other angle
like dick size
and uh last porn site visited
yeah that's good yeah search history and
then the tag was i think i'd be a pretty
good corner man for a female fighter
because i've been in enough fights with
women
where if she was losing the fight i
would just yell calm down
you know it like regenerates her
re-energizes her female rocky
yeah yeah exactly then she would beat me
up after
that's [ __ ] great female if you can
add a whole female rocky thing it's like
it's so much easier
yeah that's right that's a great that's
a great bet that's hilarious
is that too dark with the eight wage and
eight uh age and weight
on screen no i think the turn is great
because it's you make it about men so i
think like
the setup you don't know i i think
bringing it back to men is where you
make it really good i like it a lot all
right all right hit me
my angle was like uh you know when
you're a kid and you have that kid who
like he's like
like the little uh pleasures of life
aren't enough he's always like taking it
up a notch so you're like you're in the
movie theater and you're eating popcorn
he's like
throw some goobers on it he's like try
this [ __ ] take it to another level salty
and sweet and you're like all right all
right that was kind of interesting
and then you're like uh you're like oh
wow it is it is good you're like well i
don't know where that kid is now but i
know it's an
autoerotic asphyxiation you know
that's like the salty and sweet of
adulthood he's like this wasn't enough
for me i took it up a level
you know what i mean that's so true
because that is what life is just like i
need more now i need more now i need
more now i'm drinking in the shower
showers aren't enough for me anymore i'm
having a [ __ ] i'm having a shower
cocktail these days
right right it's it's always like when
those some but sometimes you need to cut
it off like
like you know you always hear about like
in high school like dude get a girl to
blow you
with ice in her mouth you're like what i
think the bj was good we're good
yeah same with that a tongue ring and
you're like we [ __ ] we did all right
we got that that's we're good
yeah yeah exactly like at some point you
got to cut it off and and auto erotic
affixiation
is the cutoff because that just kills
you every time like that's how
kung fu guy went david carradine i just
scared it
just rewatched kill bill so good that's
funny that's so true it starts young
it starts young you had an ad on two
about like child i don't know if you did
this as a kid but like
how as a kid you like jerk off in groups
oh yeah sure like it's like so weird how
horny we were but like i had a whole
thing i added on about how like we would
just like be like all right everyone get
in a corner and you just put a pillow
over your dick and jack off and you hand
a bottle of lotion around like it's
whiskey in the war
you know and then i did a whole thing
about like how uh
i had one there's always the one guy who
comes too quickly and then he's just
kind of got
the dad's in the next room so he's got
to sit there and he's like all right
guys come on
he's always like it's kid jesse was the
first one in our group and he'd be like
all right i'm out like it was cards
you know and uh right
so that yeah i kind of hit and i did the
whole thing about like uh
one of my friends from our original
jerk-off group died so i was like
grateful i didn't have to speak at his
funeral
you know cause like that would i don't
know if i would have been able to resist
as a comic
you know like ah harry always loved the
left quadrant that was his uh
that's great he went the quickest again
there we go boom oh man the jerk off in
groups i i it's nice to hear because
i've brought that up to a few guys
they're like what the [ __ ] now that's
crazy
about that everybody not everyone does
it but it's but it is a thing
yeah it's a horny it's a horny kid thing
i mean you're a horny kid and you're
like this is what we do
it's actually quite you know uh
vulnerable because you're like i do this
you do this too let's do it together
even though we'll keep our distance like
covet like look we want to be together
but we'll keep our distance
[Laughter]
but yeah like a lot of people were not
into that yeah
i dared my friend to taste it once and
that's why well
wow yeah that's [ __ ] that but that's
you tried to push it to another level
you took it a little further it didn't
work out
but you took the chance hey man that's
how chocolate milk started you know
milk is good we need more you put the
spoon of sugar on the see on the
cheerios you're right let's just keep
keeping it up
we get a seasoned assist on from
chocolate milk next episode that is not
how chocolate milk started it was not
it was not a guy asking his friend to
taste his [ __ ] that is
this is from uh yuhu and uh this is not
true
[Laughter]
exactly oh man nestle's quick that's
what you call your friend
all right we turned we brought it all
around what uh what else you guys should
we should wrap this up anything else
going on
uh no no i mean we're about to hit the
new year
um we should all get lunch or something
i mean sounds like it's lunch maybe
we're gonna grab lunch at some point
that was so fun when you me and sean hit
up
sarge's deli that was like one of my
best days of quarantine for sure that
was great it was great
great hang on so good but uh yeah i'm
doing a thing you're doing tampa this
weekend so get tickets for that i guess
if you're watching this but i'm doing
i'm doing those nowhere comedy zoom
shows i'm just working out i've got bare
bones
material here but just trying to figure
some [ __ ] out before i
start doing shows again what is that i
keep seeing that is that just a zoom
club kind of zoom but they do a good job
and it's just you know they it's
you can get like 300 people or so in
there but then you get uh
you know they only uh they mute everyone
but like 20 people so you just hear the
laughs you work it out it's
for me it's like good to get my timing
for new bits before i take it out to
real shows and i'm gonna start doing
roofs again i like doing the roofs
yes hopefully they get some [ __ ]
heaters up there and
we'll make it work we'll see man but
this was this is so fun man doing the
show we gotta
we gotta get on uh on a label or
something but i know we need to make the
audio available on like
spotify and itunes and all that but i
don't know where the [ __ ] to begin with
doing that [ __ ]
well someone hit us up and we'll figure
it out but uh keep listening keep
telling friends and uh and thanks for
watching
yes comedy
stop recording how do i oh stop